desde que tuvo edad para trabajar husein
ha salido al mar todos los días pero
está pescando ilegalmente sin licencia
como otros miembros de la comunidad de
pemba todos apátridas hussein está
indocumentado la mayoría son
descendientes de familias que llegaron
aquí en la década de 1930 tras la
independencia de Kenia nunca fueron
reconocidos Ahora hay al menos 7000
probablemente muchos más
nuestros padres eran de la isla de pemba
Pero ellos vinieron a instalarse en
Kenia
y nosotros nacimos aquí luego también
tuvimos hijos aquí
es imposible trabajar sin documentos de
identidad hussein solo puede ganarse la
vida pescando pero la práctica es
arriesgada la policía lo detiene con
regularidad
nos piden los permisos
Si no los tenemos nos arrestan nos
preguntan de dónde somos
no podemos demostrar nuestra identidad
sin papeles Entonces nos detienen y nos
llevan a los tribunales
donde Nos multan o nos encarcelan
tras la integración de otras comunidades
apátridas bajo el mandato del
expresidente urgeniata William bruto
anunció en diciembre la integración de
los pembas poniendo fin a décadas de
marginación de vuelta a la pesca hussein
quiere asegurarse de que está a salvo se
reúne con uno de los líderes de la
comunidad los documentos de identidad
aún no están listos pero pueden vivir
con normalidad
hasta el momento según la declaración
presidencial se ha ordenado a los
guardacostas que reconozcan los papeles
que hemos creado como pembas
durante todo el proceso de
reconocimiento y hasta que obtengamos
nuestros documentos nacionales de
identidad
hasta ahora les ha sido imposible abrir
una cuenta bancaria
acceder a la asistencia social o
estudiar no pueden salir de la pobreza
incluso los hospitales están fuera del
alcance
en las salas de maternidad no tenemos el
mismo acceso a los cuidados como otras
madres
por ejemplo pueden dar a luz sin gastos
médicos pero si uno no tiene papeles
tiene que pagar el médico puede exigir
cualquier cantidad
el acceso a los títulos de propiedad
también es imposible excluidos de la
sociedad los pembas no pueden demostrar
que se asentaron en estas tierras hace
décadas muali mu va a encontrarse con
los habitantes despojados para 2021 la
comunidad ha perdido más de 360
hectáreas a manos de 3 kiatas cuando
esta gente vio que no teníamos los
documentos de este lugar hicieron los
suyos y se apoderaron de todo Sin un
título de propiedad es imposible
reaccionar
lo primero que hizo el Gobierno fue
Investigar para establecer que esas
tierras son nuestras y fueron de
nuestros antepasados
las gracias al presidente
dijo que si los ladrones no las
devuelven voluntariamente
el estado las comprará y nos las
devolverá
la comunidad Lleva años luchando para
adquirir finalmente la ciudadanía
keniana el tan esperado ejercicio de
registro comenzó en marzo y malimu
recorrió el condado para asegurarse de
que todo el mundo participaba celebramos
este acontecimiento sabemos que a partir
de ahora está grabado en piedra somos
kenianos es muy importante para mí ir a
todos estos pueblos para ayudar a
nuestra gente y amiyango desde hace tres
días a pocos kilómetros de la frontera
con tanzania la población de la aldea de
vanga espera ser registrada
ahora tendré acceso a prestaciones
sociales
lo que inevitablemente mejorará mi vida
sin documentos es difícil demostrar que
cumplen los requisitos las autoridades
temen que la gente finja vivir aquí para
obtener papeles por ello recurren a los
líderes comunitarios que identifican a
cada una de las familias
el comité de auditoría se asegura de que
estas personas cumplen todos los
criterios
tres
como esta familia de aquí
está el cabeza de familia su mujer y sus
hijos
se espera que el proceso concluya en
mayo
cuando el presidente anunció esta
noticia
me sentí nacer
y cuando el proceso comenzó oficialmente
un segundo nacimiento
es imposible saber cuántos apátridas
viven en Kenia donde otras cinco
comunidades siguen teniendo derechos
limitados pero el prometedor compromiso
de Kenia desde 2017 hace albergar
esperanzas de acabar con la patrulla en
el país de forma permanente en todo el
mundo la ONU Calcula que millones de
personas viven sin nacionalidad